programming thrown out episode 49 tamper protection take it away jason hey everyone this is a double episode uh December double episode pretty excited about that um we're going to we have an amazing interview coming up and we want to give a lot of time for that so uh you know we won't uh we'll skip a lot of uh we'll usually cover in the beginning of the show and save you know our tool of the show book of the show that we had lined up for um for next month um but something i did want to talk about is what did things cost and why did things cost what they do so someone sent me a youtube video uh co-workers sent me a youtube video called uh most expensiveest uh stuff it's not stuff it's actually the s word but but you can you can figure it out but it's it's it's a show um um where they just try like they drive the most expensive car and they try on a two million dollar
programming thrown out episode 49 tamper protection take it away jason hey everyone this is a double episode uh December double episode pretty excited about that um we're going to we have an amazing interview coming up and we want to give a lot of time for that so uh you know we won't uh we'll skip a lot of uh we'll usually cover in the beginning of the show and save you know our tool of the show book of the show that we had lined up for um for next month um but something i did want to talk about is what did things cost and why did things cost what they do so someone sent me a youtube video uh co-workers sent me a youtube video called uh most expensiveest_stuff it's not stuff it's actually the s word but but you can you can figure it out but it's it's it's a show um um where they just try like they drive the most expensive car and they try on a two million dollar
pair of shoes and things like that what yeah it's crazy um it's really funny actually um and so it made me think you know i mean okay these are extreme things but but in general like why do things cost what they cost like kind of who figures that out and you know we all took economics in high school um and you talk about you know the supply curve and the demand curve and all of that, but it doesn't really explain why those curves are what they are for different things. I did a bunch of research on this, poking around on Wikipedia and reading some papers and things like that. Basically, what I learned is there's a lot of different theories and they're all true, you know, to different degrees for different products. So I'll just kind of go through them.
The first one is called the labor theory of value. And it's very simple. It just says things are worth whatever it costs to produce them. So, you know, if something's really hard to produce, such as, you know, way back in the day, salt was used as currency because it was so valuable. And it was valuable because it was very difficult to mine salt back then. Now it's very easy to mine, so it wouldn't make a good currency, obviously. But so that's the idea. but then that kind of breaks down i mean if if you you know if it's just because something is difficult to get doesn't necessarily make it useful i mean like panda bears are rare but you know they might be difficult to find but you know panda bear feces isn't worth a ton of
money you know so it's it can't it can't just be that was a stretch i know but it can't just be how hard something is to get it doesn't make that by itself doesn't work um and so um so then they came up with this idea called the subjective theory of value. And this handles, so, you know, there's, take like diamonds, for example. Diamonds are more expensive than emeralds, but they're about the same in terms of how hard it is to find them and things like that. But diamonds are more expensive just because it's part of our culture to give diamonds. So it's sort of like we've just propagated this value for diamonds for no reason. There's nothing inherently about diamonds that make them more expensive than emeralds. And so the subjective theory of value is kind of weak, right?
Because it's just like saying, well, things cost more because they cost more it doesn't really help but the reality is that there's a psychological there's sort of a group mentality like mob thinking part of this and and that just reflects that um well this is like uh diamonds are supposed to be colorless but then so if your diamond has a tint of color to it, then colored diamonds, and then now they become more valuable. Exactly, or even more ridiculous is you can get a synthetic diamond that chemically is exactly the same from a chemistry perspective as a diamond, but it's almost worthless relatively worthless right well no they charge a lot and I don't know if they need to or they just do or if it's a conspiracy but I think they only charge like 10% difference or something oh really I thought it was
like a tenth of the price no I mean like tuber zirconia or something is like a tenth but those are chemically different right right okay well yeah but you're right but the point is there I mean, like cubic zirconia or something is like a tenth, but those are chemically different. Right, right. Okay, well, yeah. But you're right. But the point is they're chemically the same diamond.
But the fact that it is different at all. Yeah, exactly. Exactly. And so there's that to think about. So you have this labor theory. You have this subjective theory. There's also one called marginalism or the theory of marginal utility and the idea there is the value of something goes down the easier it is to add
another one to the ecosystem so in other words if you look at say a loaf of bread you know if you compare you might only have one or maybe no loaves of bread at your house and so you have to go to the store and for you it's very important to get some bread right now but if you look at the whole ecosystem for you know safeway or kroger or publics or whatever supermarket you have near you for them to add a loaf of bread to their network is very simple i mean the bread manufacturers are probably stepping on bread all the time by accident because there's just so much bread that they're producing. And so the marginal utility of bread is tiny.
The same isn't true of diamonds. I mean, you don't go to a diamond factory and just see a bunch of discarded diamonds everywhere because each one is too hard to come by. And so marginalism is, is kind of connected to the labor theory, but, but it's, it's not entirely that way because for example,
um, if you're out in the desert and you don't have access to any stores or anything, uh, water becomes extremely valuable. And it didn't make water more difficult to produce. It's just that you're in an environment where you don't have access to a lot of water. And so the marginal utility goes up.
So marginalism, think of it as sort of replacing the labor theory of value kind of so um so basically there's all of these different theories they're all true in different circumstances and there's no way to tease apart you know what kind of is assigned to what so you can't say oh diamond% of the value is subjective. 10% is this. You know, it doesn't, it's very hard to do that. So how do you break down something like an iPhone? An iPhone costs, what, $600? I don't know, unlocked, a new iPhone. I don't know. I think like $600, but yeah, sure.
Sure, $700, $600, whatever. And then you always see whenever the new iPhone comes out, they say, here's how much the actual components cost and someone tries to do a really good job of estimating it and it comes to like 120 and so you have 120 of like materials cost then there's some labor to assemble iphones and some labor to develop iphones and the software that goes on them. But then there's all this extra at the end, like the profit margin. And is it a theory to say, predict how much Apple should make that profit margin?
Yeah, I mean, it's super hard. So I'll talk about, so iPhones are a restricted commodity in the sense that, you know, Apple just sets the price, right? But if you look at open commodities like say oil for example so um so with something like oil they can't really it turns out they can't really do a good job of this of teasing this apart and there's no science to to it so what they do is because only apple makes iphones but everyone who makes oil makes the same oil right right and so so they can't control those dynamics because it's just too complicated and so they um that's why they have features so if you want to buy any commodities i mean if you
buy a loaf of bread at safeway it's different different. But if you're buying 10,000 tons of bread or something, yeah, or a ton of oil or anything like that, anything that level. Barrels of oil. Right, barrels of oil. If you do any of that, there's a commodities market, and you have to say in advance, like, three months from now i want these barrels of oil um and then there's uh in the case of oil there's opec who they handle this socially so in other words if something weird happens and everyone starts asking for oil they through you know phone calls and things like that they just sort it out manually like they, they decide they need to do an auction or they call people and tell them,
buy a loaf of bread at safeway it's different different. But if you're buying 10,000 tons of bread or something, yeah, or a ton of oil or anything like that, anything that level. Barrels of oil. Right, barrels of oil. If you do any of that, there's a commodities market, and you have to say in advance, like, three months from now i want these barrels of oil um and then there's uh in the case of oil there's opec who they handle this socially so in other words if something weird happens and everyone starts asking for oil they through you(,) know phone calls and things like that they just sort it out manually like they, they decide they need to do an auction or they call people and tell them,
hey, your order got canceled because crazy stuff happened in the market. And basically the free market isn't really that free is what I learned. Well, OPEC specifically is not that, like they control the market, they manipulate it. Yeah, well, that's even worse, right? But even if you look at grain, you know, almost any kind of utility, it's all just very highly regulated.
So I'll give you another example. So in the Bay Area or in all of California, we have a drought, right? And so when there's a drought, they don't just raise the price of water until the demand goes down that's what a free market would do right but no they they impose restrictions they say you know people can only water their lawns on mondays or something like that and basically it's because they know that if they try to do some kind of free market economics, it's going to end badly, basically, because their models are wrong. It's hard to decompose the price,
and it's just going to end badly. So it's kind of amazing. I mean, I'm not trying to be glib or rude to economists or anything. I think that's amazing. I wish if I could go back to school, I would study economics. And I have a lot of, yeah, I give them a lot of credit. But the reality is, is these systems
are just not modeled well. Whether they can be is debatable, but right now they're not modeled well. And so there's a lot of social, you know, a lot of elbow grease goes into making this work the thing i remember about economics is a lot of it comes down to like predicting what a rational person should do but then there are many edge cases that break down because people aren't rational often oh that's even worse yeah that's that's that's a whole other thing. You're right. I mean, it turns out even if people are rational, the system is completely unstable.
There's something called the bullwhip effect, which you should look into. And basically, it's similar to the butterfly effect. It just says that if you make small changes, like you just barely change the price of, say, an iPhone or a barrel of oil, it causes massive change. You change the price of a barrel of oil by a cent and that causes an oil field to get shut down because there's this weird chaos theory going in there. And these are all assuming everyone's rational. They're just using mathematical models. As soon as you get into real human beings, it's even more broken.
Yeah, it's even more broken yeah it's unbelievable so anyways that's my pseudo rant but that's what I learned from from most expensive as stuff or from I guess the the the queries that derived from that anyways if you want to check that show out it is actually really funny they don't obviously talk about why things cost what they do but but they have fun putting on two million pair of shoes. All right, so without any further ado, we're going to talk to some folks at Intel. These guys are superstars at you know tamper software tampering and tamper protection
they've done definitely their fair share of I guess you'd call it gray hat gray hat and white hat hacking and it's going to be a lot of fun to talk to them about this well welcome we're here with the team from Intel
the tamper protection division I guess our team we'll let to talk to them about this. Well, welcome. We're here with the team from Intel, the Tamper Protection Division, I guess, our team. We'll let them introduce themselves in a minute. We've got Thaddeus, Mark, Steve, and Norman. So we're just going to go around the room, the proverbial virtual room, and have everyone introduce themselves.
So I guess, Thaddeus, you're up first. Hey, I'm Thaddeus. Call me Thad. Lettness. I work over at Intel. I've been there about 10 years. I used to work in the digital home group doing things like the Google TV and stuff like that. A year or two ago, I moved over to Steve and Mark's team and been working on tamper protection ever since. Mark?
Yeah, so I'm Mark Valley. I've been at Intel for almost 17 years now. I started out at the University of Florida as a mechanical engineer in my undergrad and did a master's in computer engineering and never thought I'd come west of the Mississippi, but they decided to fly me out here on their dime, and I really like what they offer. And, you know, free flights in a nice warm weather just like Florida will do that for me. Go Gators. Nice. Yeah, absolutely.
You know, I don't know how we got the record we got so far this year. That's all right. Hey, at least I think you won a game. What? I went to University of Central Florida. We went 0-12. University of Florida won many games this year, I think. No, UCF.
I know, I'm saying. Yeah, but UCF is. Yeah, UC. I know, I'm saying UCF went 0-12. UCF is up and coming. They've got a lot of the Florida talent, so I think they're going to do alright in a few years. Yep. Hi, I'm Steve Price. I'm a product manager
at Intel, and I started my career as a software developer. If any of you have some age, you'll remember WordPerfect. I was a developer of WordPerfect for Windows, or one of the many developers. And then I had the opportunity about 18 years ago to work for Intel. And Intel, you can do amazing things. It's not just on the commercial.
It's a real great place to work. And so I product manage a brand new tool called Intel Tamper Protection Toolkit. And we are excited to tell you a little bit more about that in this podcast. Very nice. Cool. I actually didn't know for the longest time what product manager was. And then I read one of the books of the show. I don't remember which episode,
but it was The Hard Thing About Hard Things by Ben Horowitz. And actually, he explains he developed this training class for his product managers, and he called it Good Product Manager, Bad Product Manager. And he used sort of that dichotomy to explain
what a product manager does, and it totally made sense after that. So if you guys wanted to know what product managers do, definitely check out that book. I felt like it really kind of explained it. The summary is, you're CEO of the product.
That's the summary. That's not a bad one. I would say my description is very close to that. It is, it's the guy that does the stuff that the coders hate doing. That's my job. All right, Norman. Thanks, guys. My name is Norm Chow.
Oh, can you hear me? Yep. We can hear you. Yep. Yeah, my name is Norm Chow. I am the marketing person for Intel Tamper Protection. I've been with Intel for five years. I love every minute of it.
Before that, I was actually a pure Windows coder for five years, so I bring a lot of technical experience. And, you know, I really appreciate the engineering team coming on this conference call and kind of describing the product to everyone. So I think we'll have Steve give us maybe a little bit of, or whoever you think is best. So I think we'll have Steve give us a little bit of a review of what's going on and then we'll go over to Jason in order to get some questions going for the team.
Perfect. So when you think of Intel, a lot of times you'll think of the bong tone that you hear on the commercials and, of course, the chips that we make for CPUs. But Intel produces a lot of software to make that hardware fly. And my team comes from the software side. And being a part of Intel, we're in the position to see a lot of the general needs in the software development community. And what we've come to understand is that coders, whether or not they want to or not, most of them don't want to, is they have to put secrets in their software.
And coders will do a lot of interesting things to hide or mask those secrets, but at the end of the day, you'll have to put in either an account name and password or a crypto key or your secret sauce that makes your code better than anyone else's. And so while they're not comfortable in doing that, they still have to write and ship their code. Another thing that we found is that developers want to do wonderful things with their code and they want to achieve personal goals and help other people. But while doing that, they want some say in how their code is used.
And so we at Intel, understanding these needs in the marketplace, with a lot of the really smart people we have. I have developed technology that helps you hide your secrets in your code and that lets you be able to respond when people try to modify your code without your permission. And that collection of capabilities and technology we call Intel Tamper Protection Toolkit. Cool. Thank you. That was an awesome intro.
So just to kind of recap, so I think a lot of people, you hear these terms like reverse engineering or code tampering, and especially you see it in the press, like someone reverse engineered some project, they were able to get in, or hackers reverse engineered some client, and now they could get into Target or what have you. But what does that actually mean?
Like if someone tampers with a binary or if someone reverse engineers some code, what are they actually doing? So reverse engineering is, it's kind of the process of pulling apart source binary code, machine code, usually, although in this day and age, we have all sorts of scripts and stuff as well,
and trying to piece back together what the original logic was. It's going to be things like disassembling the codes, going back from machine code to assembly, trying to reconstruct the flow, the structure of the code, and understand the idioms that the compilers and stuff were putting in with the ultimate goal of being able to say, you know, here's a function that does exactly what the original programmer wrote. Gotcha. Is that the same as tampering or is tampering something different?
Tampering usually starts with reverse engineering. You usually have to have some idea what you want to do. But tampering then takes it another step forward and says, I'm going to go and take your DLL or your code loaded into RAM and make some change. Maybe tweak a variable so that it's always a particular value
or change an if statement so it just unconditionally passes so you can buy you know maybe to bypass a license check or you know I mean a great example is the old game genie right any code you put in the game genie was basically code tampering it said here's an address here's a value value. Whenever somebody wants that address, give them that value. Oh, I actually never knew that. So for people who maybe are younger in the audience, Game Genie was this amazing magical thing that you plugged into your Nintendo.
And it plugged into the Nintendo, but then it offered a plug out. So you could plug a cartridge into the Game Genie, which is plugged into the Nintendo. So think of it as sort of a connector that sat in between. And then when you started the Nintendo, it just presented you with this crazy screen like you would see in some sort of cheesy CSI episode. And you would punch in these alphanumeric entries that were completely cryptic. But when you were done, you would get them from some kind of reference manual. But then when you were done, you just had infinite lives or Mario could fly or something
like that. And so I guess that's under the hood. That's actually code tampering that's making that happen. And in order to find out exactly what values to punch in and how to build that thing, they had to reverse engineer both the Nintendo and the software first. Oh, I see. So in this case, do you think they were working with the software company or were they actually reverse engineering it blind?
Well, in the Nintendo world, I thought they had to have like permissions and stuff. But I mean, certainly you can think of other platforms where, I mean, back in the Commodore 64 days and stuff like that, there were things like this as well, right? Oh, I see. That's right. GameG probably not because there were licensing issues with that back in the day. So Nintendo would probably jump on you. Cool. So obviously they didn't have the source code for any of Mario or anything like that, so they had to completely figure out by sort of poking around
what they could modify to get behaviors that they want instead of just crashing it. Gotcha. There's actually a lot of these sort of bootleg cartridges. Like there's this Noah's Ark game. It's actually a set of three it's called Bible Games, I think, or Bible Study.
It is an NES cartridge that was not licensed in any way by Nintendo but they were able to sort of handshake with the Nintendo and convince Nintendo they were a licensed cartridge. And it's probably by doing exactly what you said, by reverse engineering the input-output of the Nintendo. Yeah, in fact, there was a whole...
I forget where I read this, but there was a whole series of games by one manufacturer that actually did reverse engineer the handshake chip and started making these third-party unlicensed games. The big deal with that was that Nintendo's revenue model was that they got a cut from everybody's game. So there was some incentive for these guys to bypass that so that they can get a cut themselves.
Oh, I see, so they didn't have to pay that share. Exactly. They could just sell it to the consumer and any additional money over the top they got or they could lower the price of their cartridge. Oh, interesting. That starts to show the battle between developers and commercial entities. You're always wanting to get paid for your products and so you
put in code and then somebody reverse engineers it and finds a way around it, and so then you do something more to lock it down even more. And there's a lot of benefit sometimes. The new Nintendo stuff and the emulators and stuff were able to unlock a lot of games having reverse engineered a lot of the old Nintendo equipment. Now you can play games that aren't manufacturing more.
The hardware is slowly going out of date, but we can still play them thanks to people diving into the software and reverse engineering how they worked. Right. Yeah, one thing to understand about that whole ecosystem is that we can reverse engineer them now, but it took time. I mean, ultimately, given enough time and resources, you can, we can reverse engineer them now, but it took time. I mean, ultimately, given enough time and resources, you can pretty much eventually reverse engineer everything.
It just may be really expensive or may take a really long time. So your goal as a developer may not be that they never can break it because that's almost impossible, but to make it hard enough so that only someone who really is super motivated would do it, and hopefully there's not going to be that many motivated people.
I mean, if you're storing, you're storing the keys to Fort Knox in there there's going to be more incentive than if you're just storing some game secrets or something. Gotcha. And I think that Moore's Law plays a huge role in this. I know this is more on the cryptography side but
if you had Amazon Web Services not S3 but Elastic Cloud, Elastic Compute Cloud of today, and you went back to the 1990s, you could actually break HTTPS and you could just liquidate people's bank accounts and you would just be a god on the internet. And so, just furthering your point that given enough resources, nothing is completely secure. But as you said, it's this constant arms race between, in this case, just going back to Nintendo, between Nintendo who's trying to preserve their intellectual property
and various people who are trying to do the reverse engineering to increase their intellectual property and various people who are trying to do the reverse engineering to save, to increase their bottom line. And that goes the other direction too. When you get to the 2030s or so, don't expect your PGP encrypted stuff to work with quantum computers around. Right, exactly. Yeah, you know, and what we found too is that there's tight Fort Knox security. I think Mark brought Fort Knox, but then there's good enough security.
You just need to be a little bit better than the other guy so that when they come to you and their easy tricks don't work, then they might go looking for better targets of opportunity. And so you don't have to be super, super secure, but just more than you were before. And that buys you a lot of value. Yeah. And that goes with understanding your threat model. In other words, what attacks are you expecting? I mean, as security engineers, that's something that we often think about when we're
architecting solutions. I mean, obviously, we can't protect against, you know, the nation-state attack necessarily, but you can, you know, at what level of resource are you considering? Gotcha. It's very similar to guarding anything, guarding your home or guarding your locker in school or any of that. You know, sure, someone can come by with wire cutters and cut the lock of your locker. But that's a very high...
I mean, someone's going to be seen walking around campus with lock cutters, and that's already introducing a lot of risk for them. And unless they just really hate you for some reason, it's just not worth it. So by putting the lock, you haven't sort of eliminated completely the idea of someone breaking into your locker, but you've made it prohibitively difficult. So what are some reasons why, you know, I mean, we talked about Nintendo and about Bible games, but obviously that was much, that was, you know, I guess 20 years ago. So today, what are the big reasons why people tamper with binaries? And so who are the people nowadays who are tampering with binaries? Well, there's a bunch of reasons.
I mean, one of the big ones is curiosity. A lot of the people who poke around in binaries are students or hackers in the good sense of hackers people just to enjoy you know peeking into how stuff works people want to fix bugs if there is a a driver for an old printer and it doesn't work you know with Windows 10 you know somebody can go in and figure out how that driver works and fix it and usually that's to everybody's benefit, including the printer manufacturer. Could be to add functionality in a similar way with printers, maybe to add a new format for sending messages.
Or new cheat mode. Yep, or cheat mode. Getting into some of the more nefarious reasons, bypassing authorization checks is a big one. This might be for things like DRM or license keys for software. If you're downloading Wares, you find the cracked version of the program, right? Spreading malware. A lot of the way that malware spreads is by infecting other binaries. And so there you're diving into the binary and finding somewhere to stuff your malware. And then generally
just to maliciously change behavior. If you want to sneak a man in the middlethe-middle attack in to sniff somebody's financial information as they're doing transactions online and that sort of stuff, if you can hop into the browser, that's a good place to do it, right? Oh, I see. So you look for some code that handles the,
you know, when you type in your password and it turns it into little asterisks in the browser, like you would inject something right there and know that you're getting, hopefully, hopefully for the attacker, you're getting passwords and things like that. Okay, that makes sense. Are there, as far as the, so you mentioned hobbyists. Are there also, I mean, is this mostly individuals?
Are there, you know, like, is there like organized crime? Like, are there massive entities that are doing this? Oh, heck yes. Or is it mainly people in their basement or what? I mean, if you look at, it's getting more and more organized all the time. I mean, if you look, there are like international gangs now that it's not drugs anymore, but it's all about hacking stuff. I mean, very well organized, pretty scary groups that do all sorts of things that are very financial nature. They're very much organized as businesses and they're not the lone hacker in the basement that you'd think
of. Yeah. So I was at Black Hat this last summer, and they were showing the nature of what you call malware or the black market industry. And you can go and you find the right places, and you can find a hacked kiosk, let's say, on the market that whoever hacked it is selling it now for someone else to exploit or to get gain from it. So there is a lot of activity, a lot of it very organized with very, very skilled people out there just wanting to benefit from others. So it's a very vibrant market, if you could say. Gotcha. It's not totally along the line of reverse engineering,
的。是的。所以今年夏天我在黑帽大会上，他们展示了你所谓的恶意软件或黑市行业的本质。你可以去寻找合适的地方，比如市场上有一个被黑客入侵的报亭，无论谁黑了它，现在都在卖给别人去利用它或从中获利。因此，这里有大量的活动，其中很大一部分是非常有组织的，有着非常非常熟练的人，只想从别人身上捞取好处。所以可以说，这是一个非常充满活力的市场。明白了。这不完全符合逆向工程的路线，
but I was trying to get my Windows product key before I upgraded to Windows 10 just in case something went wrong, and I was extremely careless and ran this program that gave me my product key and also installed something terrible. And before I could remove it, it had gone into my browser kind of local settings and pulled out my credit card. And sure enough, the next day, someone went with my credit card to Home Depot and bought a bunch of restricted chemicals, which is actually quite terrifying.
但我当时只是想在升级到Windows 10之前获取我的Windows产品密钥，以防万一出了什么问题，结果我极其粗心，运行了这个程序，它给出了我的产品密钥，同时也安装了一些可怕的东西。在我能够删除它之前，它已经进入了我浏览器的本地设置并取出了我的信用卡的资料。果不其然，第二天，有人拿着我的信用卡去了家得宝（Home Depot），买了一堆受限制的化学品，这其实是非常可怕的。
I mean, they bought things that you can only buy in certain amounts, but because they were masquerading as me, they were able to buy more than probably they would have by themselves. And I mean, yeah, that whole thing is just frightening. It screams of like a huge organization, right? Cool.
我的意思是，他们购买的数量是有限制的，但因为他们冒充了我，他们买到的东西可能比他们自己去买还要多。而且我的意思是，整件事简直太吓人了。这听起来就像是一个巨大的组织，对吧？酷。
So I think we've kind of, you know, sort of touched on this, but what are the consequences for not protecting against tampering? If someone just runs regular old, you know, GCC produces, maybe GCC with debugging symbols and no optimization and starts distributing the binary, you know, what are the consequences of that? The big one is usually the money motive, right? Lost revenue if people are able to install your software without a license, possibly legal liability if you're supposed to be protecting, say, somebody's financial information or content
所以我想我们已经，你知道的，算是接触到这一点了，但是如果不防范篡改会有什么后果呢？如果有人只是运行普通的老旧的，你知道的，GCC生成的，也许是带有调试符号且没有优化的GCC，并开始分发二进制文件，你知道，这会有什么后果？最大的问题通常是金钱动机，对吧？如果人们能够在没有许可证的情况下安装你的软件，就会导致收入损失；如果你本应保护某个人的财务信息或内容，
that you're licensing and you let people bypass your DRM, you could actually be liable for that. A big one that we think about is reputation. Just somebody being able to get in and monkey with your code and then make you look bad. Bad press, yeah. Yeah. Within Intel, we look at things like loss of intellectual property,
而你却让人们绕过了你的DRM（数字版权管理），你实际上可能会承担法律责任。我们考虑的一个大问题是声誉。仅仅是有人能够潜入并搞砸你的代码，然后让你看起来很糟糕。负面报道，是的。是的。在英特尔内部，我们会关注诸如知识产权丢失之类的事情，
like trade secrets, stuff that isn't actually patented, but shows how stuff works. Usually you don't want that. Like algorithms? Yeah, generally. If you've got an algorithm that is really that much better in your product, then, you know, you might want to protect that so that somebody else can't get at it.
比如商业机密，那些实际上没有申请专利，但展示了事物运作原理的东西。通常你不会想要那种情况。比如算法？是的，一般来说。如果你的产品中确实有一个好得多的算法，那么，你知道，你可能想保护它，以免别人得到它。
Possibly loss of customers. If your mobile payments get hacked, then people are going to stop using you. Take a look at Chipotle if you want to see how fickle people are nowadays, right? And it can even be life and death. You know, more and more we've got things like traffic lights and power
可能会失去客户。如果你的移动支付被黑了，那么人们就会停止使用你。如果你想看看人们现在有多善变，看看Chipotle就知道了，对吧？它甚至可能是生死攸关的问题。你知道，我们越来越多地拥有交通信号灯和电力等，
controlled by computers, even airplanes and cars, right, with the computer controlled cars nowadays. Yeah, so if somebody can hack in and gain control and get their software running where yours should be,
由计算机控制的东西，甚至是飞机和汽车，对吧，现在的电脑控制汽车。是的，所以如果有人能够侵入并获得控制权，并在你的软件应该运行的地方运行他们的软件，
you know, somebody could lose their life over. Yeah, I guess that's a good point. I mean, I think a lot of times hacking is the vague term that people use. And, you know, initially it's like, oh, you're going to talk to some web service and try to understand its behavior, and then you're going to try to send it some code, some exploit, whatever. And I mean,
你知道的，有人可能会因此丧命。是的，我想这说得对。我的意思是，我觉得很多时候黑客攻击是人们使用的一个模糊的术语。而且，最初的情况是，哦，你要和一个网络服务对话，试着了解它的行为，然后你要试着给它发送一些代码、一些漏洞利用程序什么的。我的意思是，
I guess, right. Some kind of like black. Yeah, that's one way of doing it. But the other way is like you're saying, if you're running a server, that's a program and someone can get that program and look at it and figure
我想是的。某种类似于黑客的。是的，这是一种方法。但另一种方法就像你说的，如果你正在运行一个服务器，那是一个程序，有人可以拿到那个程序并看一看，通过查看源代码弄清楚，
out by looking at the source code, like, Oh, Hey, look, there's a, you know, not balanced check string print here.
哦，嘿，看，这里有一个，你知道的，未平衡检查的字符串打印。
Oh, well now I know exactly what to send it to hack it. Then that's much worse. Which is exactly what stuff like Heartbleed was, right? I mean, somebody sets up an overflow and all of a sudden they can start whatever code they want running on your server. There's not much we can do about that from the Tampa protection side. But if their code starts to interfere and interact with protected code, we can at least identify that and stop it at that point. So does the tamper protection work at all with the trusted security modules that are
哦，好吧，现在我确切地知道该向它发送什么来破解它了。那可就糟透了。这正是像“心脏出血”（Heartbleed）漏洞之类的事情，对吧？我的意思是，有人设置了一个溢出，突然之间他们就可以在你的服务器上运行他们想要的任何代码了。从防篡改保护的角度来看，我们对此无能为力。但如果他们的代码开始干扰和互动受保护的代码，我们至少可以识别出来并在那个时候阻止它。那么防篡改保护是否与某些计算机中包含的，
in some computers, or is it that kind of unrelated? So actually, tamper protection is a software sort of trusted execution environment. So there's no special hardware required other than IA. So in a perfect world, everyone would have the very latest SGX technology that's in the latest Skylake processors. And they'd use that sort of hardware protected execution environment. The problem is that very few people have those right now. And let's say you're a Netflix and you want to deploy something.
受信任的安全模块协同工作，还是说这基本上是毫无关系的？所以实际上，防篡改保护是一种软件式的受信任执行环境。因此，除了IA（英特尔架构）之外，不需要特殊的硬件。所以在理想世界中，每个人都会拥有最新Skylake处理器中的最新SGX技术。并且他们会使用那种硬件保护的执行环境。问题是现在很少有人拥有这些。假设你是Netflix，你想部署一些东西，
I mean, you'd love everyone to have Skylakes, but realistically you want to sell to a lot of people and not very many people have them yet. So until those are widely deployed everywhere, you're going to need some stopgap until you have hardware support. Right, and I think if you're in the business of tampering the binary, you would just get some older hardware to do the tampering, I think, right?
我的意思是，你希望每个人都有Skylake，但实际上你想把产品卖给很多人，而拥有它的人并不多。因此，在这些技术被广泛部署到各处之前，在获得硬件支持之前，你需要一些权宜之计。对吧，我想如果你从事的是篡改二进制文件的业务，你就会找一些旧硬件来做篡改，对吧？
Presumably. If you waited in time, once everyone has a protected hardware execution environment, then it's going to be much harder to tamper in the same ways. That actually might be a good topic. I brought it up, but you want to go ahead and explain maybe what hardware modules,
大概吧。如果你耐心等待，一旦每个人都有了受保护的硬件执行环境，那么以同样的方式进行篡改就会困难得多。这其实可能是一个好话题。我提出来了，但你想继续解释一下硬件模块是什么，
what a trusted execution environment, like what does that mean? So what that typically means is that general code running on the computer can't see into what's going on. Imagine it like a sort of a little box somewhere. So a great example of this is you can imagine that if you look at an older PC, there's this thing called the ME, the manageability engine, if you have an Intel processor. And the manageability engine is actually a separate processor that is sort of an embedded device.
受信任的执行环境是什么，这到底意味着什么？所以这通常意味着计算机上运行的一般代码无法窥视正在发生的事情。可以把它想象成某个地方的一个小盒子。一个很好的例子是，如果你看一台旧PC，如果你有英特尔处理器，这里有一个叫做ME（可管理性引擎）的东西。可管理性引擎实际上是一个独立的处理器，有点像一个嵌入式设备。
And the main CPU cannot access its memory, cannot talk to it in any significant way, so it can't really inspect what's going on. So you can think of the thing that that processor is running as an environment that's protected from the CPU. So even the OS, if you somehow compromise the OS, you can't see what's running on those things. And similarly, with the latest Intel processor, the Skylake models, you in fact can do that on the main CPU in such a way that the main CPU can actually see what's going on either in the process itself or even in memory because the memory is encrypted
主CPU无法访问其内存，无法以任何显著方式与其对话，所以它无法真正检查发生了什么。因此，你可以认为该处理器正在运行的东西是一个与CPU隔离的保护环境。所以即使是操作系统，如果你以某种方式破坏了操作系统，你也无法看到这些东西上面运行的内容。同样，使用最新的英特尔处理器，即Skylake型号，你实际上可以在主CPU上做到这一点，这样主CPU实际上可以看到进程本身内部或内存中正在发生的事情，因为内存是加密的，
from the other parts of the CPU. So even the OS doesn't have the power to go in there and see what's going on. Oh, I see. So that protects you against sort of attacking the OS or attacking other binaries getting into I guess like explored IDFC and things like that.
不受CPU其他部分的影响。因此，即使是操作系统也没有权力进入那里查看发生了什么。哦，我明白了。所以这可以保护你免受攻击操作系统或其他二进制文件的攻击，进入像探索IDFC之类的事情。
Right. But if you attack it, you have to have a program. So let's say you have some hacking tool that can write to memory. Well, the problem is that the memory that you're writing to is essentially not accessible to even that tool. So there's no other program that can run into that memory other than the program that owns it. Oh, now I get it.
对。但如果你攻击它，你必须有一个程序。假设你有一些可以写入内存的黑客工具。嗯，问题是你要写入的内存本质上甚至连那个工具都无法访问。所以除了拥有它的程序之外，没有其他程序可以运行到该内存中。哦，现在我懂了。
It makes the discovery of the hack very difficult. It's literally impossible. Yeah, and also, you know, let's say that you're a programmer and you're writing code, you know, either in your basement or you're part of a small company. To get a piece of software on the manageability engine is a difficult proposition, right, because it's a secure environment. And very few people write to that level of security or to, you know, that have access to get their software on the engine. And it's, as Mark said, it's a separate computer, almost within a computer, intended to run securely.
这使得发现黑客攻击变得非常困难。这简直是不可能的。是的，而且，你知道，假设你是一个程序员，你在编写代码，不管是在地下室还是在一家小公司里。要在可管理性引擎上部署软件是一件困难的事情，对吧，因为它是一个安全的环境。很少有人能写出那种安全级别的代码，或者说有权限让他们的软件运行在引擎上。正如马克所说，它是一个独立的计算机，几乎就像计算机内部的计算机，旨在安全运行。
But what a lot of developers want to do is they just want to write their code. And they want to be able to write their code in such a way that people don't mess with them. And so what we provide is a software trusted execution environment. As we said, it's not impervious, but it's better than nothing. And it's a way that gives you a little bit more comfort and security to know that when you write your code and you put you have to put your secrets in or you want to be able to detect when someone has changed something to get a different behavior then you have some some Avenue recourse as a developer to to minute either minimize the impact or at least slow them down to the point to where they might they'll think it's not
但许多开发者想要做的只是编写他们的代码。他们希望能够以一种别人不会搞砸的方式编写代码。因此，我们提供的是一个软件受信任执行环境。正如我们所说，它不是刀枪不入的，但总比没有强。它能给你带来一点额外的安慰和安全感，让你知道当你编写代码并放入机密，或者想要检测是否有人改变了某些东西以获得不同的行为时，作为开发者，你可以采取一些补救措施来尽量减少影响，或者至少减缓他们的进度，让他们觉得不值得麻烦，
worth the trouble and go on and mess with someone else's code. Gotcha. So that is a good segue to the next question, which is how does this actually work? In other words, are we talking about something that scrambles your code before it compiles it? Is it Stone Compiler? Is it a virtual machine?
从而去搞砸别人的代码。明白了。所以这是一个很好的过渡，引出了下一个问题，那就是这到底是如何工作的？换句话说，我们讨论的是在编译之前打乱你的代码的东西吗？它是编译器吗？还是虚拟机？
What is actually the tamper protection product? Well, I'll just take a product manager's crack, and then the real answer will come from the geniuses. But really, if you look at tamper protection product, it's basically two main components. One of them is a command line executable. We call it IProt, Intel Protector for long, but it's an IProt, it's IProt and it's a command line. You type in some input parameters and you include, one of those parameters is the input file. And this input file is your binary. It could either be a Windows binary or an Android binary, DLL form. And then it spits out another executable that will run on any Intel processor, but this one will be self-encrypting and self-modifying.
防篡改产品到底是什么？嗯，我先以产品经理的角度来试着回答一下，然后真正的答案将由天才们来揭晓。但实际上，如果你看一下防篡改产品，它基本上由两个主要组件组成。其中一个是命令行可执行文件。我们称之为IProt，即Intel Protector的简称，但它就是IProt，它是IProt，并且是一个命令行。你输入一些输入参数，其中一个参数是输入文件。这个输入文件是你的二进制文件。它可以是Windows二进制文件或Android二进制文件，DLL格式。然后它会吐出另一个可以在任何英特尔处理器上运行的可执行文件，但这个文件将是自加密和自修改的。
And so the difference between the input binary you give it and the output binary it spits out is the same identical functionality, but as it runs, it will be encrypting itself, unencrypting itself, modifying the code to make it very difficult for someone to figure out what's going on. So that's one component, and that's a command line executable. Another one is a library called CodeVerify,
因此，你输入的二进制文件和它吐出的二进制文件之间的区别在于，功能完全相同，但在运行过程中，它会自我加密、解密、修改代码，使别人很难弄清楚发生了什么。所以这是一个组件，它是一个命令行可执行文件。另一个是一个名为CodeVerify的库，
and how that's used is you weave the CodeVerify into your code, and what it allows you to do is reach out from this trusted executable environment. So just going back to IPROT, the binary it spits out, we call a software trusted executable environment. And from within that base, then you can reach out to other unprotected pieces of code and check it. You know, are you still the same piece of code that I expect you to be? And if it isn't, then we can flag it. And because it's in a TEE, it becomes difficult for an attacker, let's say, to change the signal from zero to one,
它是如何使用的呢？你将CodeVerify融入到你的代码中，它允许你从这个受信任的可执行环境中伸出触角。回到IProt，它吐出的二进制文件，我们称之为软件受信任可执行环境。在这个基础内部，你可以延伸到其他未受保护的代码段并进行检查。你知道，你还是我期望的那个代码段吗？如果不是，那么我们可以对其进行标记。正因为它在一个TEE（受信任执行环境）中，攻击者想要改变信号（比如将零变成一，
you know, from a yes to a no, for example. So that's pretty much that. It's very simple. We have some other ancillary pieces that help developers do their work, that help with what we call we call code bind that lets the verification piece check a predefined version of the file so you know when it's been changed but pretty much just a security compiler you can call it and a library that helps you go out and check and verify the integrity of your code. Yeah, and speak a little bit to sort of like the workflow of how you'd work. I mean, if you're using something like GCC or something like that,
或者从是变成否）就会变得很困难。所以基本上就是这样。它非常简单。我们还有其他辅助组件，帮助开发者完成工作，协助我们称之为代码绑定（code bind）的功能，它允许验证部分检查文件的预定义版本，以便你知道它何时被更改了。但基本上，你可以称它为一个安全编译器和一个帮助你出去检查和验证代码完整性的库。是的，稍微讲讲工作流程。我的意思是，如果你使用的是GCC之类的内容，
essentially, you know, you would take your program and separate out what you think the critical sensitive functionality is. I mean, you don't want to necessarily put the whole program in this because it has performance consequences. And then that turns into a shared library, either an SO or a DLL, depending on what platform you're going into. And then that is your sort of root of trust,
本质上，你知道，你会提取你的程序，并分离出你认为关键的敏感功能。我的意思是，你不一定要把整个程序都放进去，因为这会对性能产生影响。然后它变成一个共享库，无论是SO还是DLL，取决于你所进入的平台。然后那是你的信任根，
your thing to start with. And so you compile it through GCC, you get an SO out for a DLL, then you run that DLL through our tool, and then you have a new DLL with the same entry points, same functionality, but it's not going to be very easy to sample with our first engineer.
你开始的东西。然后你通过GCC编译它，得到一个SO或DLL，然后通过我们的工具运行该DLL，然后你就会得到一个新的DLL，具有相同的入口点和相同的功能，但它不会那么容易被逆向工程篡改。
And that's for IProt. Yeah. And then for the code verify technology, you know, you take a binary, you know, EXE, I believe we can even take EXEs for that, I know DLLs, NESSOs, and you generate, basically, it's like a cryptographic hash signature of that file using a tool called CodeBind that I think Steve mentioned.
那是针对IProt的。是的。然后对于CodeVerify技术，你知道，你拿一个二进制文件，EXE，我相信我们甚至可以为此接受EXE，我知道DLL、SO，然后你生成，基本上，就像使用史蒂夫提到的一个叫CodeBind的工具，为该文件生成一个密码学哈希签名。
And then from that, you can check all or even just parts of your execution file against that. And that's kind of the lightweight, relatively fast iProt output because it's self-modifying and in fact it keeps very little of the executable code in plain text at any given time. So as you're running it's constantly trying to pull stuff down and transcript it to the next phase of execution. So there's a lot of heavy-duty processing going on there. So that's the heavyweight thing. You want to be in as little as possible,
然后在此基础上，你可以对照该签名检查所有的或是部分的可执行文件。这就是那种轻量级的、相对快速的IProt输出，因为它是自修改的，事实上它在任何给定时间内都只把极少的可执行代码放在纯文本中。所以在运行的时候，它会不断地拉取内容并将其转录到执行的下一个阶段。所以这里面有很多繁重的处理工作。这就是重量级的东西。你希望尽可能少地使用它，
only for your most secure code, and then jump out to this much faster engine for more of the general, is my code still untampered? Could you maybe walk us through the flow, like a function level, like what kind of function? So you said you wouldn't want it all to be there. So your main is running, you're doing something, you want to log a user in or whatever.
只用于你最安全的代码，然后跳转到这个快得多的引擎，用于更一般的检查：我的代码是否仍然未被篡改？你能带我们过一遍这个流程吗，比如函数级别，什么样的函数？所以你说过你不会希望所有东西都在那里。所以你的main函数在运行，你在做一些事情，你想让用户登录或者干别的。
Like what would be the kind of thing you'd want to do where you would jump to the environment and then come back? And how does a person not just bypass the trusted environment? Like how do you prevent them from not going there? Okay, great question. So the first way you do that is you've got to put something of important value in the trusted environment. In other words, something that if they were to just rip out and skip it, then whatever
什么样的场景下，你会想要跳转到这个环境中然后又回来？以及，人们怎么能不只是绕过受信环境呢？你如何阻止他们不去那里？问得好。所以你首先要做的第一件事，就是在受信任的环境中放入一些有价值的重要东西。换句话说，如果他们直接把它拆下来跳过，那么你的代码所执行的任何功能将不再起作用。所以我们可以举一个例子，比方说我们正在做一个视频解码器。然后这个视频解码器正在解密一些视频流。然后它有一个解密功能。然后它将该视频流以解密形式传递给另一个缓冲区。假设你其实并不是那么在意。一旦字节被解密，它们就被解压缩了。所以有很多，你知道的，视频的尺寸是巨大的。
functionality that your code performs would no longer work. So one example we could have here is let's just say we're doing a video decoder, for instance. And then the video decoder is decrypting some video stream. And then it has a decrypt functionality. And then it passes that video stream on to some other buffer in decrypted form. And let's say you don't really care so much. Once the bytes are decrypted, they're uncompressed. So there's lots of, you know, the size of the video is huge.
所以你不会，没有人想要原始位。但你想保护加密位不被轻易转来转去。所以，你知道，一种攻击，你知道，会是，嘿，我将直接调用你的，好吧，第一次攻击将是，我将直接查看敏感应用程序内部的密钥和解密密钥。这就是你可能想要用IProt保护的东西的一个例子。所以你通常会把实际的解密阶段放在那里。但你面临的问题是，假设任何人都可以调用这个。所以我要保持你的东西原样。我
So you're not going to, no one wants the raw bits. But you want to protect the encrypted bits from easily being transferred around. So, you know, one attack, you know, would be, hey, I'm just going to call your, well, the first attack would be I'm just going to look at the key, the decryption keys inside your sensitive application. So that's an example of something that you might want to protect with iProt. So you'd typically put, you know, the actual decryption stage in there. And the issue you have though, so let's say anybody can call this. So I'm just going to keep your thing as is. I'm
不会修改它。我不会破解它。我只是要调用你的API，然后抓取解密后的位，轰，我搞定了。然后我可以把它们写入磁盘并做任何我想做的事。所以这是你可以从那里使用CodeVerify的一个地方。因此，你可以做的是，当你准备将位传递给系统中下一个对这些位进行处理的模块时，你可以确保你交出的那个模块不是某个恶意应用程序、恶意程序或修改过的程序，它会把位写入磁盘或某个文件，
not going to modify it. I'm not going to hack it. I'm just going to call your API and then I'm just going to grab the decrypted bits and bam, I'm good. And then I can write them to disk and do whatever. So that's one place where you can use code verify from there. So what you can do is when you're ready to pass the bits off to some other module in your system that does the next thing with those bits, you can make sure that the one you're handing it off to is not some rogue application or rogue program or modified program that's going to write it off to disk or something to a file,
而是你预期的那个模块，比如显示驱动程序之类的东西。这就是你将在解密的每个周期中，在交出位之前使用CodeVerify对其进行检查的地方。所以，你知道，攻击者要绕过这一点，就必须提取密钥，这更困难，或者他们必须找到某种方法
but it's going to be the expected module that is the display driver or something like that. And that's where you would use code verify to sort of inspect it before you hand the bits off every cycle of the decrypt. So, you know, an attacker to bypass that would, you know, have to extract the key, which is more difficult, or they would have to find some way
修改链中的某些内容以便将其写入磁盘。所以这些都是你要避免的事情。是的，是的。我只是想说，你知道，马克过去曾把这种场景描述为一个“解密的傻瓜”。所以，你知道，有人交给你，你知道的，他们隔离了执行解密模块，
to modify something in the chain to be able to write it to disk. So those are the things you want to avoid. Yeah, yeah. I was just going to say, you know, Mark in the past has described that scenario as a decrypting fool. And so, you know, someone hands you, you know, they isolate the module that does the decryption,
然后他们说，哦，好吧，我刚刚交出了一些加密的位，它就会给我吐出好的位。如果执行解密的东西无法识别谁在调用它并强制确保它是它所期望的那个，那么这就是“解密的傻瓜”场景。完全正确。所以你可以使用CodeVerify。除了检查你的下游交付对象之外，你还可以检查你的调用者，以确保他们被授权实际使用你。因此，如果你做了一些敏感的事情，就像你说的，你知道，如果你做了一些事情，比如
and they say, oh, okay, I just handed some encrypted bits and it's going to spit me out the good ones. And if the thing that does the decryption can't identify who's calling him and enforce that it's the one he expects, then that's the decrypting fool scenario. Exactly. So you can use code to verify. In addition to checking your downstream who you deliver to, you can check your callers to make sure that they're authorized to actually use you. So if you do something sensitive, like you say, you know, if you do something like
给定用户名返回密码，你可以确保只有被授权向用户名索取密码的人才能拿到，或者你是一个保险箱，你在打开保险箱，你只向授权的你知道的组件打开保险箱，这样人们就不能只是拿起你的代码在任何他们想用的地方使用，而不去管
return passwords given a username, you can make sure that only someone who's authorized to ask for a password back from a username or whatever, or you're a safe, and you're opening the safe, you only open the safe to authorize you know components so then people can't just pick up your code and use it wherever they want and who cares
它到底是什么而不去修改它，这就是IProt发挥作用的地方，因为为了让他们能够以某种方式修改它以绕过这些检查，这正是困难所在，所以你需要IProt作为在出去做所有这些检查之前站稳脚跟的安全地方。因为否则，如果他们只是改变了检查，那就白忙一场了。我的意思是，就像如果你没有IProt来写这个，
what it's exactly that without modifying and that's where the iPod comes in is that in order for them to be able to modify it in such a way to bypass these checks that's what makes it hard so you need the iPod is sort of somewhere safe to stand before you go out and do all this checking. Because otherwise, if they just change the checks, then it's all for naught. I mean, like if you were to write this without iPod,
作为一个逆向工程人员，我要做的是，我会找出if检查在哪里，如果这个模块是受信任的，我就把它永远改成无条件通过，直接假设它是受信任的。所以你需要确保这种攻击很难做到，这样检查就不会浪费时间，所以你能带我过一遍吗？
as a reverse engineer, what I would do is I'd find out where the if check is, if this module is trusted, and I just always change it to unconditional, go ahead and assume it's trusted. So you need to make sure that that attack is hard to do so that the check isn't a waste of time so can you kind of walk me through
所以这里有机器码，我有这个，然后有这些，我想像IDS就是其中之一，但是有一堆这些反编译器你可以从互联网上下载，最后你会得到——如果我错了请纠正我——但我相信你会得到带有织入汇编语言的C代码，因为在无法做得更好的地方它就是这样，并且C代码，它试图去——你会得到if条件以及
so there's this machine code and I have this and there's these I think there's like IDS is one of them but there's a bunch of these decompilers that you can download off the internet and you end up with and correct me if i'm wrong but i believe you end up with you know c code with some assembly woven in where it couldn't do anything better and and and the c code it it tries to uh you end up with ifs and and a
一点点逻辑，当然所有的变量名都是A、B、C、D，因为这些没有被保留，对吧？从那里开始，这就是你做事的方式，你是这个意思吗？你会找到这个if。也许你会遍历通过反编译器生成的C代码。你会重新编译它并逐步浏览它，看到，哦，这一行就是它检查CD密钥的地方。我打算把那个代码删掉或者让它永远为真之类的。所以如果你试图做同样的事情，你从互联网上下载其中一个反编译器并在二进制文件上运行它。
little bit of logic um of course all the variable variable names are A, B, C, D, because those aren't preserved, right? And from there, that's how you would do things is what you're saying. You'd find this if. Maybe you'd step through this C code that you've generated through decompiler. You'd recompile it and walk through it and see, oh, this line right here is where it's checking for the CD key. And I'm just going to make that. I'm just going to delete that code or make it always true or something. So if you tried to do the same thing, you get one of these decompilers off the internet and you run it on a binary.
并且假设整个二进制文件都在防篡改保护之下。那么这看起来是什么样的？是不是就像一团糟？其实本周早些时候出于好奇，我在我们的一个二进制文件上运行了IDA Pro。那是一个非常昂贵的工具。是的，那是一个非常昂贵的工具。它更多用于反汇编，但它会将反汇编拆开，
And just assume that the entire binary is under tamper protection. So what does that look like? Is it just like a complete mess? I ran IDA Pro for Curiosity earlier this week, actually, on one of our binaries. And that has a very expensive tool. Yes, that is a very expensive tool. It's more for disassembly, but it takes the disassembly apart
并创建像你谈到的程序流结构。当我用它来对付未混淆的代码时，它显示了一个非常棒的流程，与原始结构映射得非常好。当我查看加密的代码时，我看到了一些汇编指令和几块东西去写入随机内存，然后它就以调用一个未定义函数结束了，
and creates a program flow structure like you're talking about. And when I did it against the unobfuscated code, it showed me a really great flow, mapped really well to the original structure. When I looked at the encrypted code, I saw a couple of assembly instructions and a couple of blocks of stuff going off writing to random memory, and then it just ended in a call to an undefined function,
这实际上，你知道的，了解它是如何运作的，这正是我所期望看到的。但实际上，它不能超越这一点，因为大多数时候，正在被调用的函数要么是我们边走边自己写的，要么是我们在对汇编代码进行突变的过程中一路解密出来的。哦，我明白了。现在我觉得有点明白了，所以你们程序所做的是，它创造了一些东西——它创造了一个二进制文件，由于其自修改的特性，它根本无法表示为源文件——没有那种C语言，没有可以解释正在发生的事情的C语法，你实际上必须遍历每一个可能的执行阶段，追踪它追踪的每一个路径，
which is actually, you know, knowing how it works, that was what I expected to see. But really, it can't go beyond that because most of the time, the functions that are being called are either ones that we write ourselves as we go or ones that we have decrypted along the way as we've been mutating the assembly code. Oh, I see. Now I think it's kind of click so so so what your program does is it creates something it creates a binary that just cannot be represented as a source file because of its self-modifying nature like there there's no sort of c it just there's no c syntax that could exist that could explain what's happening you would actually have to step through every possible phase of execution, track down every path that it traces
以便弄清楚将执行什么指令，因为在任何给定的静态时间点，它们中的大多数不仅被加密了，而且被多次加密，必须被多次解密才能可见。是的，这些工具通常会做什么，比如IDA Pro之类的，
in order to figure out what instructions would be executed because at any given static point in time, most of them are going to be not just encrypted, but have been encrypted multiple times and have to be decrypted multiple times in order to be visible. Yeah, what these tools typically do, the IDA pros and things,
这就是我们所说的静态分析。换句话说，它们会查看磁盘上的二进制状态，并尽其所能从该状态中进行逆向工程。问题是，当你拥有不断被加密和解密的东西时，在每个阶段，理想情况下，你希望在它运行时运行它，而不仅仅是在静态时。因为在代码解密之前，它无法告诉你关于加密代码的任何信息。而我们的工具的工作方式是，在任何时间点，只有极小一部分代码是明文的。因此，要进行这种分析需要付出更多的工作。另一个优势是，我们实际上使用该代码
that's what we call static analysis. In other words, they take a look at the binary state on disk and they try to reverse engineer it as best it can from that state. The issue is when you're having things that are constantly being encrypted and decrypted, at every stage, ideally, you would want to run it while it's running, not just simply at rest. Because there's nothing it can tell you about the encrypted code until the code became unencrypted. And the way our tool works is that only a very small portion of the code at any point in time is ever in the clear. So it's much more work to be able to do that sort of analysis. And the other advantage of that is we actually use that code
作为加密密钥的一部分。一个状态的代码是加密到下一个状态的密钥的一部分。因此，如果你做了更改，它就会开始变成这种级联反应，最终通常会导致某种保护异常，从而导致处理器回滚到操作系统并杀死进程。完全正确。这就是我们在这种环境中防止被篡改的主要方式，
as part of the key to encrypt. The code at one state is part of the key to encrypt to the next state. So if you make a change, it starts to become this cascading reaction that ultimately generally results in protection exception of some sort that will cause the processor to throw back to the OS and kill the process. Exactly. That's the primary way we protect against tampering in this environment
即通过修改代码，你正在修改解密密钥，这会导致解密出完全合法的指令，而这些指令其实是完全的垃圾，注定会引导你走向崩溃。酷。是的，太棒了。非常感谢你的解释。真的，这让我从一个对逆向工程和防篡改一无所知的文盲，到现在觉得我可以向别人解释它是如何工作的了。这太棒了。所以对于像帕特里克这样的人——我不知道帕特里克的情况，所以对于像帕特里克——我不知道帕特里克，但对于像我这样对逆向工程和
is that by modifying the code, you're modifying the decryption key, which results in decrypting perfectly legal instructions that are total garbage that are bound to lead you to a crash. Cool. Yeah, that's awesome. Yeah. Thank you so much for explaining that. Really, it took me from a complete Luddite of reverse engineering and tamper protection to now I think I could explain to somebody how it works. So that's totally awesome. So for other people like Patrick, I don't know about Patrick, so for other people like, like Patrick, I don't know about Patrick, but for other people like me who know absolutely nothing about reverse engineering
防篡改一无所知，但想进入这一行的人。而且，你知道，他们真的觉得这非常令人兴奋，他们想了解更多，并想做你们正在做的事情。什么样的，你知道，也许他们还在上学，或者他们正在考虑重返校园。什么样的背景对这项工作有用？所以，不要选Java。所以拜访，你知道的，我的意思是，你知道，我们现在正在招聘的一件事，我们正在努力招聘人才，
temper protection, but want to get into this line of work. And, you know, they really, they think it's, it's very exciting and they want to learn more and they want to, to be doing sort of what you're doing. What kind of, you know, maybe they're still in school or they're thinking about going back to school. What kind of background is useful for this work? So not Java. So please, you know, I mean, you know, one of the things we're actually hiring right now, we're trying to hire people,
要找到理解机器如何运作的人是非常具有挑战性的。我的意思是，不仅仅是，你知道，栈里发生了什么，栈是如何布局的，你知道，当函数调用发生时会发生什么，指针是如何工作的，你知道，对机器如何工作的那层理解。因此，不仅对顶层感兴趣，比如“编码”一个应用程序，而是了解当你用C语言说某些话时，你真正是在告诉机器做什么，
and it's very challenging to find people nowadays who understand how the machine works. I mean, not just, you know, what happens in the stack, what happens, you know, how stacks are laid out, you know, how things, what happens when a function call happens, you know, how pointers work, just, you know, that layer of understanding of how the machine works. So an interest in not just at the top level, like, quote, unquote, coding an application, but understanding when you say something in C, what are you really telling the machine to do you know so things that you might do in school i mean like you know anything that talks with assembly or sort of microcontrollers
所以你在学校里可能会做的事情，比如任何与汇编或微控制器有关的事情，
you know back in the day we had like the motorola 68ks and stuff like that but understanding what your c code does even writing an inline assembly on your own, this is one thing you can do, is go ahead and write yourself a very small C program and then try and look at its disassembly and see if you can crack open the manual and sort of figure out what's going on. Yeah, like Mark says,
你知道，过去我们有像摩托罗拉68K之类的东西，但是了解你的C代码的作用，甚至自己编写内联汇编，这是你可以做的一件事，就是去给自己写一个非常小的C程序，然后尝试查看它的反汇编，看看你是否能打开手册并弄清楚发生了什么。是的，就像马克说的，
understanding assembly languages, instruction sets. I remember one of the early things I did was I wrote a hash function. I started out in Pascal and then rewrote it multiple times in assembly, just understanding how every instruction worked and how to maximize performance on that. Honestly, one of the things I do for fun is I read the C and C++ standards for understanding how compilers work. And, I mean, I couldn't write a compiler, honestly.
理解汇编语言、指令集。我记得我早期做的事情之一就是编写一个哈希函数。我从Pascal开始，然后用汇编语言重写了多次，只是为了了解每条指令是如何工作的，以及如何在此基础上最大化性能。老实说，我乐此不疲的一件事是阅读C和C++标准，以了解编译器是如何工作的。而且，说实话，我写不出一个编译器。
It's something I would like to do at some point. And I've written parsers for C. And obviously, I know a bit about the assembly side of things. But it does mean that you can write a compiler, but understanding, you know, what's happening at a lower level in the language, you know, what happens in memory when you have an object and it's, you know, inherits from another object and, you know, what is a virtual function table and, you know, what is happening on the stack when you call a virtual function, that sort of stuff is, you know, kind of where we sort of stuff is, you know,
这是我在某个时候想做的事情。我写过C语言的解析器。显然，我对汇编方面的东西略知一二。但这并不意味着你可以写一个编译器，而是要理解，你知道，在语言的较低级别发生了什么，你知道，当你有对象且它继承自另一个对象时内存中发生了什么，你知道，什么是虚函数表，你知道，当你调用虚函数时栈上发生了什么，这类事情是，你知道，
kind of where we think that that's, you know, kind of the problems we look at all day in and day out. Yeah. I'd echo what Thad said. And, you know, even more, that brings up the point. One thing you can get from school that's very useful is compiler classes. That is a really good place to sort of the interface for the language and the machine meet. And I think people who understand how the machine works are going to be much better
我们觉得这就是我们日复一日研究的问题所在。是的。我赞同Thad的观点。而且，更重要的是，这提出了一点。你可以从学校获得的一个非常有用的东西是编译器课程。那是语言和机器交汇的接口的好地方。我认为理解机器如何运作的人会是比那些离得很远的人好得多的
programmers than people who are, you know, really far away. You can still be a, you know, a decent programmer at a high level for big picture things, but it gives you a little extra edge when you wondering what some, what's going on with some bug or some crash, if you have some inkling about how the machine actually works. And I would highly recommend it to anyone who wants to be a programmer. And that could be the most fun, too. I mean, you might spend, you know, 90% of your time integrating two systems,
程序员。对于宏观的大局事情，你仍然可以成为一个高水平的、不错的程序员，但如果你对机器实际如何运作有一点直觉，当你遇到某个漏洞或某种崩溃时，它会给你带来一点额外的优势。我强烈向任何想成为程序员的人推荐这一点。这也可能是最有趣的部分。我的意思是，你可能会花，你知道，90%的时间在集成两个系统上，
and it's just a lot of reading documentation and writing APIs that work together and things like that. But then you encounter some kind of performance issue where maybe you have to rewrite something in C or you have to understand, as Mark said, what's really happening under the hood. Why is this code so slow? And that is often the most fun part of the job.
那只是大量的阅读文档和编写协同工作的API之类的事情。但随后你会遇到某种性能问题，可能你必须用C重写某些东西，或者你必须像马克所说的那样，了解底层究竟发生了什么。为什么这段代码这么慢？这通常是工作中最好玩的部分。
Well, to be fair, it's somewhat of an advantage because I have some of that experience to be one of the few people on a team that knows how to do that to oh yeah look at the assembly go into gdb and say give me the assembly instructions what why is this taking too long because it's a rare skill so people value it and you can really you don't need it often I would say if you're a normal software engineer not doing something specifically related to that you may not need it that much but when it comes time and you can pull out the big guns and do that people get really happy very fast yeah i mean you can really you know that's a skill set that is shrinking more and more we see out there and the people who you know know stuff like that are gold to us but they're also
好吧，公平地说，这算是一种优势，因为我有一些那样的经验，成为团队中少数几个懂得如何做到这一点的人——哦，是的，看汇编，进入gdb，说“告诉我汇编指令，为什么这需要这么长时间？”——因为这是一项稀有技能，所以人们很看重它，而且你其实不需要经常用到它。我想说，如果你是一个普通软件工程师，没有做专门与此相关的事情，你可能不需要太多，但当时候到了，你可以掏出大招来做这件事时，人们会非常快地感到高兴。是的，我的意思是，你可以真的，你知道，那是一个正在越来越萎缩的技能组合，我们在外面看到，那些了解这些东西的人对我们来说是无价之宝，但对他们所在的任何软件团队来说也是无价之宝，
gold to whatever sort of software team they're on, just to echo what Patrick said. So I have a question about self-modifying code. How does that not get flagged by the antivirus? There's a couple. Great question. Or is the antivirus just that crappy? Because if I was going to write an antivirus, that'd be the first thing I would just flag as a virus.
呼应帕特里克刚才的话。所以，我有一个关于自修改代码的问题。这怎么不会被杀毒软件标记呢？有好几个。好问题。还是说杀毒软件就是那么逊？因为如果要我写杀毒软件，那将是我首先标记为病毒的东西。
So not all self-modifying code will get flagged to start with, but you do run into a lot more risk of it. And Mark has looked into that more than I have, so I'll let him talk about it. Right, and so that's sort of the double-edged sword about all these trusted execution environments. On one hand, you would like to have your code somewhere protected so that no one else knows what's going on in the container with it,
因此，并非所有的自修改代码一开始都会被标记，但你确实会面临更高的风险。马克在这方面比我研究得更多，所以我让他来谈谈。对吧，所以这是所有这些受信任执行环境的“双刃剑”。一方面，你希望你的代码被保护在某个地方，这样容器里的其他人就不知道发生了什么，
but that also, malware authors, virus writers also would love that same thing so that potentially legitimate processes on the machine can inspect and see what the code is going to do before it's executed. And that's a tug of war in all these sorts of TE environments. I mean, the way it's often solved is that there's some sort of signature that's done so that you at least say where we were, you know, where this came from, so that if maybe it fails, but after or does something malicious, but after that, you know, you can trace back to, you know, it came from Microsoft, or it came from
但这同时也意味着，恶意软件作者、病毒编写者也希望得到同样的东西，这样机器上潜在的合法进程就无法在代码执行之前检查并查看代码要做什么。这就是所有这些TEE环境中的拉锯战。我的意思是，通常的解决方法是进行某种签名，以便你至少能够说明我们来自哪里，或者这个代码来自哪里，这样如果它失败了，或者做了什么恶意的事情，在此之后，你知道，你可以追溯到，它来自微软，或者它来自
a non trusted party. So maybe next time, I won't trust him. So you can decide sort of what level of trust you give to each one, if it's one that has no trust, then you better run it, you know, on a clean machine isolated. But if it's something that came from someone who you trust and you say, okay, I'll let it run and I'll trust it. It's going to do what I expect. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, I had this when I was cleaning off this virus off my machine, I noticed that I was kind of expecting it to be more malicious than it was. I went through all my services and sure enough, there was a service that was, I don't remember the name of it, but it was definitely, it is a name that stood out. And, um, and it, as we said in the beginning, you don't have to be, uh, for, for, for most cases,
一个不受信任的方。所以也许下次，我就不会信任他了。所以你可以决定对每个人给予什么样的信任级别，如果它是一个没有信任的方，那么你最好在一个干净的、孤立的机器上运行它。但如果它来自你信任的人，你说，好吧，我让它运行，我相信它。它会做我期望的事。是的，这说得通。是的，当我从机器上清除这个病毒时，我注意到我有点期望它比实际更具恶意。我检查了我所有的服务，果不其然，有一个服务，我不记得它的名字了，但它绝对是一个引人注目的名字。而且，正如我们在一开始所说的那样，你不必在大多数情况下，
you don't have to be Fort Knox. You shouldn't expect someone from CSI or... Who's the guy from Mission Impossible? I'm totally drawing a blank. The Scientologist? Tom Cruise. You don't expect Tom Cruise to get into your PC. It's Bing Reims who does that, right?
你不必成为诺克斯堡。你不应该指望来自CSI或者……《碟中谍》里那个家伙是谁？我完全想不起来了。那个山达基教徒？汤姆·克鲁斯。你不会指望汤姆·克鲁斯潜入你的PC。是文·瑞姆斯做那个，对吧？
Yeah, right. But you can actually stop 99% of the problems. yeah right but yeah but you could actually stop you know 99% of the problems and for average people out there who don't have that much at stake who aren't holding Fort Knox in their basement
是的，没错。但你实际上可以阻止99%的问题。是的，没错，但你实际上可以阻止你知道的99%的问题，对于那些没有那么多利害关系、地下室里没有诺克斯堡的普通人来说，
they get you know a phenomenal amount of protection so very cool Fort Knox hardware is the way to go I don't know is there even. Fort Knox hardware is the way to go. I don't know. Is there even, is Fort Knox still significant? Because I heard the whole gold thing. Well, obviously gold doesn't match to dollars anymore. That went away a long time ago. But I think even, I wonder if, I don't know if Fort Knox even holds that much. They claim they do. But if you trust the conspiracy theories, they haven't done an audit in a while so it may all be gone and spent
他们得到了非同寻常的保护，所以非常酷。诺克斯堡硬件是王道，我不知道，甚至还有吗？诺克斯堡硬件是王道。我不知道。甚至还有，诺克斯堡现在还重要吗？因为我听说了整个黄金的事情。好吧，很明显黄金不再对应美元了。那是很久以前的事了。但我甚至认为，我不知道诺克斯堡是否还持有那么多黄金。他们声称他们有。但如果你相信阴谋论，他们已经很久没有审计了，所以可能全都没了并且花光了。
oh yeah it's just holding UFOs they just spent it and didn't tell anyone oh okay I want the keys to that center of the internet that they visited the Avengers that's where I want oh yeah and like somewhere in Norway
哦，是的，它只是在保存UFO，他们只是花掉了然后没告诉任何人。哦，好吧，我想要复仇者去过的那个互联网中心的钥匙，那是我想要的地方。哦，是的，还有挪威的某个地方
or something yeah yeah it's always in some frigid environment even Oh, yeah, and like somewhere in Norway or something? Yeah. Yeah, it's always in some frigid environment. Even the Watchmen, right? The main base. I don't want to spoil the movie, but there's one part where they go to an evil lair,
或者什么的，是的，是的，它总是在某个寒冷的环境中，甚至哦，是的，就像挪威的某个地方或其他地方？是的。是的，它总是在某个寒冷的环境中。甚至《守望者》也是，对吧？主基地。我不想剧透电影，但有一部分他们去了一个邪恶的巢穴，
and it's always in some glacier somewhere. So do you guys find yourself, so if we want to say the cat and the mouse, the good guys and the bad guys, we'll just all pretend that we trust you, as we talked about, and that you're the good guys. Do you have to put on your bad guy hat and do stuff to keep up on the latest and greatest of
它总是位于某个冰川里。所以你们发现自己，如果我们想说猫和老鼠，好人和坏人，我们都假装我们信任你们，正如我们所讨论的那样，你们是好人。你们是否必须戴上坏人的帽子，做一些事情来跟上最新、最棒的
disassembly techniques and that kind of stuff? Do you find yourself... Somebody mentioned going to Black Hat, that kind of stuff. How much would you say is that? Yeah, go ahead. So to be a good security guy, you've got to be able to think like the bad guys. The only difference between us and the bad guys should be what side we're on.
反汇编技术以及诸如此类的东西？你们发现自己……有人提到去黑帽大会，诸如此类的东西。你会说这占了多大比例？是的，请继续。所以要成为一个好的安全人员，你必须能够像坏人一样思考。我们和坏人唯一的区别应该是我们站在哪一边。
If you're not thinking about the possible attacks and the possible ways to exploit systems, then you're going to be blind to everything. So, I mean, in everything, even, you know, for most of us, it's not just in what we do now, but in other systems, like, you know, someone is, you know, setting up a system to, you know, lines to, you know, for a fair or something like that. We, you know, can see the potential exploits there. I mean, you've got to be able to look at everything as a potential attack. Every time I got on an airplane, that's the way I think. Yeah, that doesn't go well for me
如果你不考虑可能的攻击和利用系统的可能方法，那么你将对一切视而不见。所以，我的意思是，在一切事情中，甚至，你知道，对我们大多数人来说，不仅仅在我们现在做的事情中，还在其他系统中，比如，你知道，有人在设置一个系统，为了，你知道，集市之类的线路。我们，你知道，可以看到那里的潜在漏洞。我的意思是，你必须能够把所有东西都看作潜在的攻击。每次我上飞机，我都是这么想的。是的，这对我很不利，
because I don't typically start talking about it. I shouldn't talk about this. You're listening. So how much would you consider yourself, yeah, so you guys mentioned that, like you think in a security mind, you even say like as security, I don't know what you say,
因为我通常不会开始谈论它。我不应该谈论这个。你在听。那么你认为自己有多少，是的，所以你们提到，就像你们有安全思维一样，你们甚至说作为安全，我不知道你们怎么说，
engineer or security researchers or security, like how much of it would you say is that versus people who just say like, oh, I'm a programmer and don't assign that kind of label. Like, is there a real difference between programmers who program with security minded and the rest? There is, yeah. I mean, if I would say one, the big difference is, you know, there's lots of skills that you pick up over time, as far as idioms and things like that, that are, you know, takes lots of training. But the most important skill is being able to sort of understand the threats, the potential threats, the potential attackers and the potential risks and what you're willing to risk.
工程师或安全研究员或安全人员，你会说这其中有多少是相对于那些只是说“哦，我是一个程序员”并且不给自己贴这种标签的人？程序员中，具有安全意识的程序员和其余的人之间真的有区别吗？有的，是的。我的意思是，如果我要说一个，最大的区别是，你知道，随着时间的推移，你学到了很多技能，至于惯用法之类的事情，你知道，这需要大量的训练。但最重要的技能是能够理解威胁、潜在威胁、潜在攻击者、潜在风险以及你愿意承担什么风险。
I mean, you know, there's a consequence to security, right? I mean, you could have max security and then your users can't do anything and you don't want that, right? So you've got to sort of at least understand sort of what you want what your users want and what the right balance is gotcha it'd be like having you know 12 locks on your door i mean it's sure but it just would take you a long time to get in exactly this might get a little meta but when you're writing the code to do the tamper protection these these processes you said that encrypt a executable or encrypt a library and that kind of stuff.
我的意思是，你知道，安全是有代价的，对吧？我的意思是，你可以拥有最高级别的安全性，然后你的用户什么也做不了，而你并不希望这样，对吧？所以你必须至少理解你想要什么，你的用户想要什么，以及正确的平衡点是什么。明白了，这就好比在你的门上装12把锁——当然可以，但这只会让你进去得很慢。精确。这可能会变得有点元编程，但是当你编写代码来进行防篡改时，这些进程——你刚才说加密可执行文件或加密库之类的东西。
When you're writing that code, do you guys have like a pretty set strict set of guidelines you follow to make sure that code itself isn't filled with flaws? Or is it something that you kind of like have an intuitive sense as an individual when you guys do code reviews? Do you have extra things you check to make sure you're not introducing problems? Well, there's a couple layers of validation, right? I mean, there's one thing where you, you know, when you're doing the initial design for, is this thing going to work? How are you going to exploit it just from a design point of view? And then there's the actual implementation stuff where that's where the code reviews come in. Does it conform to, you know, the design?
当你编写该代码时，你们是否有相当固定的一套严格准则来确保代码本身没有充满漏洞？还是说当你们进行代码审查时，这更像是你们作为个人的一种直观感觉？你们是否有额外的检查来确保没有引入问题？嗯，这有几层验证，对吧？我的意思是，有一件事是，你知道，当你进行初步设计时，这东西能行吗？仅从设计的角度来看，你将如何利用它？然后是实际的实现部分，代码审查就是在这个时候发挥作用的。它符合设计吗？
And in every design, no design is perfect. There's always, you know what the, you know, you make trade-offs, you make decisions on, you know, what you protect more, what less, what potential threats are you willing to give up for additional benefits. And even with our tool, the toolkit that we're providing, we're giving the developers the ability to make that trade-off. There's a couple of like really simple options
而且在每一个设计中，没有哪个设计是完美的。总会有，你知道的，你会做出权衡，你会就你保护什么更多、什么更少、你愿意放弃哪些潜在威胁以换取额外利益做出决定。即使使用我们的工具，我们提供的工具包，我们也让开发者有能力做出这种权衡。有几个非常简单的选项
you can give on the command line that provide sort of a trade-off between the level of security and the level of performance you get. You can give a command line, like how frequently do you mutate? How often do you go through the code and do we change stuff?
你可以在命令行中提供这些选项，它们在安全级别和性能级别之间提供了一种权衡。你可以提供一个命令行，比如你多久变异一次？你多久遍历一次代码并修改一些东西？
If you do it very frequently, it'll be much more secure, but at the same time, it'll be a lot slower. If you do it less frequently, less secure, but your code will run faster. And this is for the application level sort of stuff, and there's similar trade-offs that we make all the time. So we come together in meetings and talk about the trade-offs,
如果你非常频繁地这样做，它会安全得多，但与此同时，它会慢得多。如果你不那么频繁地这样做，安全性会降低，但你的代码运行会更快。这是针对应用程序级别的各种事情，我们一直都在做出类似的权衡。所以我们在会议上聚在一起讨论这些权衡，
talk about the threats, and then based on those, we make some of our best calls based on what we perceive to be the best interest of the users, or we can provide a knob that the user can tune and say, hey, it'll be up to the user. We'll give them these tools, and we'll warn them how to use them and put it in their hands. But in the toolkit code that you guys write itself,
讨论威胁，然后基于这些，根据我们对用户最佳利益的理解做出一些最好的决定，或者我们可以提供一个旋钮供用户调整并说，嘿，由用户决定。我们将这些工具交给他，并警告他们如何使用它们，将其交到他们手中。但在你们自己编写的工具包代码中，
is that such that it's, oh, I guess kind of like public key encryption. You can know the methodology. It doesn't really help you. Or is it that you have to take special steps in writing those tools so that if someone got a hold of them, they wouldn't be able to now exploit everyone who's ever used your toolkit before. I think there's a little bit of both.
它是这样的吗？哦，我想有点像公钥加密。你可以了解方法论。这其实对你没什么帮助。还是说你在编写这些工具时必须采取特殊的步骤，以便如果有人得到了它们，他们将无法利用以前使用过你们工具包的所有人？我觉得这两方面都有一点。
There are definitely, you know, part of the way the thing works is that, you know, there are, you know, obviously some secrets that are stored in this thing that's encrypting and decrypting. So knowing how that behaves can give some insights to attackers. But in addition, that's not going to help them with, you know, breaking an existing thing or at least tampering with something is they're
毫无疑问，你知道，事情运作方式的一部分是，你知道，有一些秘密存储在这个用于加密和解密的加密东西中。所以了解它的行为可以为攻击者提供一些见解。除此之外，这并不能帮助他们破解现有的东西，或者至少篡改某些东西，因为他们
still going to have to, you know, extract all the code and reverse engineer it. So there's a little bit of both. Yeah. We, we take some effort like in our release process. We'll,
仍然必须提取所有的代码并对其进行逆向工程。所以两方面都有。是的，我们在发布流程中确实付出了一些努力。我们会
we'll make sure we scrub out a lot of debug messages, any symbols that, that really say exactly how we're doing something. And, you know, let us trace a specific, say, a given instruction all the way through from input until, you know, we know where it's encrypted in the final output. We'll make sure we scrub that sort of stuff out. But, you know, it's kind of that defense in depth, right? How deep do we want to defend it? And we don't encrypt the entire program with its own methodology because that would have a huge performance impact.
确保清除大量的调试信息，任何真正说明我们如何做某事的符号，并且，你知道，让我们追踪一个特定的指令，比如从输入一直到我们知道它在最终输出中被加密的地方。我们会确保清除这类东西。但是，你知道，这就是纵深防御，对吧？我们希望防御到多深？而且我们不会用它自己的方法论来加密整个程序，因为那会对性能产生巨大的影响。
Is the toolkit protected by the toolkit? The code verified library is, by its very nature, has to be able to be encrypted by iProt. But we don't generally encrypt much else of the toolkit with itself. Because of the nature of what it is, what the tool set is, the risk analysis just hasn't taken us there at this point. Although I'm sure Steve hears this, he's like, hmm, that's something I can put on the backlog. Yeah, right. To do inception system.
工具包本身受到工具包的保护吗？代码验证库本质上必须能够通过iProt进行加密。但我们通常不会用它本身来加密工具包的其他大部分内容。由于它本身的性质，即工具集的性质，风险分析在这一点上还没有把我们带到那里。虽然我确信史蒂夫听到这个时会想，嗯，这是我可以加入待办事项列表的东西。是的，没错。来做盗梦空间系统。
You just keep encrypting yourself and just watch the binary get bigger and bigger. And it does get bigger. And you don't have the answer. But you mentioned earlier, if you're running on an Intel processor, you get this stuff. What happens if you run the code signed by this on a non-Intel processor, like an AMD processor? Okay, Intel instruction set. Okay, sorry.
你只是不断地加密自己，然后看着二进制文件越来越大。它确实变大了。而你却没有答案。但你刚才提到，如果你在英特尔处理器上运行，你就会得到这些。如果你在一个非英特尔处理器（如AMD处理器）上运行由其签名的代码，会发生什么？好的，英特尔指令集。好吧，抱歉。
AMD will work. We don't support ARM today. It's something we've definitely looked at. Oh, well, how does the Android work then? Well, there's Intel Android, right? Oh, I didn't know that. Okay. That explains that.
AMD可以运行。我们目前不支持ARM。这是我们绝对考虑过的事情。哦，那安卓是怎么运行的呢？嗯，有英特尔安卓，对吧？哦，我不知道。好吧。这就说得通了。
For everybody listening, Intel does support Android. In fact, Intel is one of the biggest contributors to the kernel. I did not know that. I mean, I know iPhones are all ARM, and so I just assumed that Androids were all ARM, too. I did not know at all. So I learned a lot of things today. Obviously, we so I just assumed that Androids were all ARM, too. I did not know at all. So, learned something. Learned a lot of things today. Obviously, we're hoping to change that. We're hoping, you know, we can convince, you know, Apple
对于所有听众，英特尔确实支持安卓。事实上，英特尔是内核的最大贡献者之一。我以前不知道。我的意思是，我知道iPhone全都是ARM，所以我只是以为安卓也全都是ARM。我完全不知道。所以我今天学到了很多东西。很明显，我们——所以我只是以为安卓也全都是ARM。我完全不知道。所以，学到了一些东西。今天学到了很多东西。很明显，我们希望改变这一点。我们希望，你知道，我们可以说服苹果，
we've got a good enough product that, you know, they can put it in their phones and stuff like that. You know, that's what Intel is trying to do. But in order to do that, we've got to make sure that it runs really well. You know, it runs really well in IA. So, that's one of the things we're doing. Well, not for the iPhone case, but... Yeah, and there are the iPhone case. Yeah. And there are actually Apple. Right. Yeah, but there are actually
我们有一个足够好的产品，你知道，他们可以把它放在他们的手机之类的东西里。你知道，这就是英特尔正在努力做的事情。但为了做到这一点，我们必须确保它运行得非常好。你知道，它在IA上运行得非常好。所以，这是我们正在做的事情之一。嗯，对于iPhone来说不是，但是……是的，还有iPhone的情况。是的，实际上还有苹果。对的。是的，但实际上还有
Intel phones, actually. Of course, I think the first one just started shipping in the US a short while ago, but I think most of them are like in markets like China and India and stuff like that. I actually saw it. Oh, cool. I actually saw an ad for one. Where was I? I think it was in Russia when I was
英特尔手机。当然，我想第一款刚刚不久前开始在美国出货，但我认为大部分是在中国和印度之类的地方。我 faktisk 看到过。哦，酷。我实际上看到过一个广告。我在哪里来着？我想是今年夏天去那里旅行时在俄罗斯
traveling there this past summer. I saw an ad for a Zen phone in Russia. An Intel Zen phone. Oh, very cool. And so Zen is owned by Intel then? No, no, no. So Intel does not sell phones, right? We sell process. Oh, I see. So we sell it to...
看到的。我在俄罗斯看到了一个Zen手机的广告。一个英特尔Zen手机。哦，非常酷。所以Zen是英特尔旗下的吗？不，不，不。所以英特尔不卖手机，对吧？我们卖处理器。哦，我明白了。所以我们把它卖给……
Got it. So when you do tamper protection for an Android thing, is there different heuristics that you use? Because obviously battery life is more of a concern, right? Got it. have a big thing to do, but again, we put that in the developer's hands. It's the same fundamental trade-offs even on an Intel device and a laptop, which a lot of the form factors are. So again, if you crank it up a lot, you'll get more security, but more processing means more battery drain. So again, we put that
明白了。所以当你们为一个安卓设备做防篡改保护时，你们使用的启发式方法会有所不同吗？因为显然电池寿命是一个更大的问题，对吧？明白了。有很大的事情要做，但同样，我们将这一点交到了开发人员手中。即使在英特尔设备和笔记本电脑上，基本的权衡也是一样的，许多外形尺寸也是如此。所以同样地，如果你把它调得很高，你会得到更多的安全性，但更多的处理意味着更多的电池消耗。所以同样地，我们把它
in the developer's hands, but we don't specifically right now have automated tuning is what we call it when you adjust the security version performance trade-offs. But that's something that we're planning to add in future versions. Cool. Very cool.
交给了开发人员手中，但目前我们没有专门提供我们称之为自动调优的功能，也就是当你调整安全版本与性能之间的权衡时。但这正是我们计划在未来版本中加入的东西。酷。非常酷。
And so just to explain the deployment from your side. So you sell a piece of software, someone buys, installs it on their machine, and then they have those tools that they can integrate into Visual Studio or into their make files or what have you, Gradle, what have you. Yes. Actually, you can actually get it for free right now. The beta,
那么只是为了解释你们这边的部署。所以你们销售一款软件，有人购买并安装在他们的机器上，然后他们拥有了这些工具，可以集成到Visual Studio中，或者集成到他们的makefile中，或者随便什么，Gradle，随便什么。是的。事实上，你现在实际上可以免费获得它。测试版，
you can download from our website and you can download it and try it out without paying for it for this version. Oh, that is awesome. Wow. Yeah, I'm so glad you said that. Yeah, definitely. If you're interested in this stuff, you should definitely do that. Everyone at home should check that out. You should build a Hello World and then run this on it and see what happens. We are very interested.
你可以从我们的网站下载，你可以下载它并试用它，这个版本不用花钱。哦，太棒了。哇。是的，我很高兴你这么说。是的，绝对的。如果你对这个感兴趣，你绝对应该这么做。家里的每个人都应该去看看。你应该构建一个Hello World，然后在此基础上运行这个来看看会发生什么。我们非常感兴趣。
Anything users want to tell us about it, the beta is there because we really want to know what people want to do with it. So if you try it, give us feedback. We want feedback. We are most hungry for feedback. Yeah, I mean, if you build something that does some kind of Monte Carlo estimation or whatever,
用户想对我们说的任何关于测试版的事情，都是因为我们真的很想知道人们想用它做什么。所以如果你尝试了，给我们反馈。我们需要反馈。我们最渴望得到反馈。是的，我的意思是，如果你构建了一些做某种蒙特卡洛估计之类的东西，
I mean, tic-tac-toe or whatever, and you run binary tampering on it and your tic-tac-toe or whatever and you run binary tampering on it and your tic-tac-toe game doesn't work anymore, let them know. I'm sure they would love to talk to you. A few more things. The URL for that is at software.intel.com
我的意思是，井字棋或随便什么，你在上面运行二进制篡改，而你的井字棋或随便什么以及你运行的二进制篡改，如果你的井字棋游戏不能工作了，让他们知道。我确信他们会很乐意和你交流。还有几件事。它的网址是 software.intel.com
slash tamper dash protection. Norm, do we have the Hello World video up there? I recently just did a quick sort of, you know, in Visual Studio, just a quick, you know, like a six-minute video that basically shows you how
斜杠 tamper dash protection。诺姆，我们的Hello World视频放上去了吗？我最近刚做了一个快速的，你知道的，在Visual Studio中，只是一个快速的，你知道的，就像一个六分钟的视频，基本上向你展示了如何
to do a really dumb, you know, Hello World-style program and run it through iProp. And I'm not sure if it's been published yet. Norm, do you know? Or maybe it will have had been published by the time this gets published. Oh, nice use of the, what is it, the past participle or something?
做一个非常愚蠢的，你知道的，Hello World风格的程序，并通过iProp运行它。我不知道它是否已经发布了。诺姆，你知道吗？或者也许等这个发布的时候它就已经发布了？哦，好棒的用法，那个什么，过去分词还是什么的？
Will have had been published. Nice. I think it's the future past participle. Future past perfect, I think. Something like that, yeah. Yeah, Thad went to a good school. Oh, I was on a vacation with my family, and there was a juggler. And there weren't a lot of people in the audience.
将已经被发布。太棒了。我想这是将来完成式。将来完成过去时，我想。类似的东西，是的。是的，萨德上过一所好学校。哦，我和家人去度假时，那里有一个杂技演员。观众不多。
And so he said, who wants to go on the stage? And my wife yelled, this guy does. And so I ended up on the stage. And he said, do you know? And he mentioned mentions i honestly don't remember the lady's name but it's some lady who could shoot a bow and arrow over her shoulder and i guess she's some famous famous uh lady of that time a 13 1400 i don't i don't remember the name that's what it is he goes he goes do you do you know any do you know annie oakley and I said, and I knew he was going to shoot a bow and arrow. He hit a coke
所以他说，谁想上台？我妻子喊道，这个人想。所以我最后上了台。他说，你知道吗？他提到了——老实说我不记得那个女士的名字了，但那是某个可以把弓箭搭在肩后射箭的女士，我想她是那个时代某个著名的、著名的女士，13、14世纪的，我不、我不记得名字了，就是那样，他说，他说，你知道吗，你知道安妮·奥克利吗？我说，我当时就知道他要射弓箭。他打掉了我头上的一个可乐罐。
can off my head. I said, did she shoot a bow blindfolded? And he goes, you went to public school, didn't you? It's like all sad trombone played in the background. I don't know if we got an answer about whether the video was posted. I'm waiting on pins and needles. We could actually go to the website and see.
我说，她蒙着眼睛射箭吗？他说，你上过公立学校，对吧？就像背景里播放了一段悲伤的长号声。我不知道我们是否得到了关于视频是否发布的答案。我正拭目以待。我们实际上可以去网站上看看。
I think we may have lost Norm. I recommend going to the website and seeing if it's there. If it's not, go back again. Yeah, the marketing video is up there. I know that. We are actively getting collateral up there based on – I think Mark was at EndefCon this last week
我想我们可能失去诺姆了。我建议去网站上看看它是否在那里。如果不在，再返回去。是的，营销视频在那里。我知道这一点。我们正在积极地根据——我想马克上周去了黑帽大会
and so he's learned some more about what we want to put up on that site. Actually, I just remastered it like two nights ago, so I don't know if they managed to get it through all the appropriate legal channels. You're like a media mogul. Actually, no, it was my second
所以他了解了一些关于我们想放在那个网站上的东西。实际上，就在两个晚上前我刚刚重新制作了它，所以我不知道他们是否设法让它通过了所有适当的法律渠道。你就像一个媒体大亨。其实，不，那是我的第二次
time using Camtasia. The first time was with the first try. But I've learned so much. So if you like the sound of the voices on the podcast, tune into the video. That's right. So do you find at an environment like Black Hat where I typically...
使用Camtasia。第一次是一次试用。但我学到了很多。所以如果你喜欢播客里的声音，请收听视频。没错。那么你们发现在黑帽大会这样的环境中，我通常……
I know it's both researchers and people trying to explain. It's kind of a mix of people. But are they generally receptive to this kind of thing? Or are they kind of like, oh, that's not going to be fun when that comes out? No, you know, yeah. So there's all kinds of people that go there. You know, there's a lot of, you know, IT enterprise types. There's coder types.
我知道那里既有研究人员，也有试图解释的人。这是一个混合了各种人的地方。但他们通常对这种事情持接受态度吗？还是他们有点像，哦，那东西出来的时候可就不好玩了？不，你知道，是的。所以去那里的人形形色色。你知道，有很多，你知道的，IT企业类型的人。有程序员类型的人。
There's, you know, government types that want to protect. And so this kind of technology is of high interest. And it's not the same thing as like network firewalls and things. So you'll see security defense in depth is a phrase you'll hear a lot in the security space. And so there's a lot of people at certain layers, and the people that are focused and interested in binary security, definitely this is right down their alley.
有，你知道的，想要保护的政府类型的人。所以这种技术具有很高的兴趣。它和网络防火墙之类的不一样。所以你会看到安全纵深防御是你在安全领域经常听到的一句话。所以有很多人在某些层面上，而那些专注于和对二进制安全感兴趣的人，这绝对是他们的拿手好戏。
I always thought it'd be cool to go to DEF CON. I'd always be terrified to bring any electronics, but I've never been able to come up with a legitimate work reason to go. Just don't connect to the network. Yeah. I know, I heard what Snowden said. I think I'm not taking the phone with me. Yeah, I'll be that guy who goes
我一直觉得去DEF CON会很酷。我总是很害怕带任何电子产品，但我从来没有找到一个合法的去那里工作的理由。只要不连接网络就行。是的，我知道，我听到了斯诺登的话。我想我不会带手机去。是的，我会成为那个去
to DEF CON and leaves with no personal information. I know, it's already happened to me once. Yeah, at DEF CON, there's a big video of flashing out IP addresses and MAC
DEF CON并且没有带走任何个人信息的家伙。我知道，这已经发生在我身上一次了。是的，在DEF CON上，有一个大视频，闪烁着在DEF CON上扫描过的设备的IP地址和MAC
addresses of devices that have been scanned at DEF CON and so it's kind of a wall of shame so definitely keep your devices off yeah don't bring them there to test them no
地址，所以这有点像耻辱墙，所以一定要关掉你的设备，是的，不要带它们去那里测试，不，
and then melt them as soon as you walk out yes sell it to somebody else oh that's nice of you we can start a whole enterprise around that a business model I think the Russian mafia already has a speed dial oh
然后在你走出去的那一刻融化它们，是的，把它卖给别人。哦，你真好。我们可以围绕这个建立一整套企业，一个商业模式。我想俄罗斯黑手党已经有速拨电话了。哦，
alright well did you guys have any last things you wanted to leave us with? Anything we didn't bring up? Any questions we should have asked you but didn't? Please encourage your audience to study more low-level stuff so we have more people to hire with the right skills. Yeah. I mean, there's so much to do. And low-level is, I think, going to become more and more important. I mean, there's so much to do. And low level is, I think, going to become more and more important. I mean, we had basically 10, 15 years of cloud. And now there's Internet of Things, there's drones, there's autonomous vehicles, there's tamper protection.
好吧，你们有什么最后的话想留给我们吗？有什么我们没有提及的事情吗？有什么我们本该问你但没有问的问题吗？请鼓励你们的观众学习更多底层的东西，这样我们就有更多具备正确技能的人可以雇佣。是的。我的意思是，有太多事情可做了。而且底层技术，我认为，将会变得越来越重要。我的意思是，我们基本上经历了10年、15年的云计算。现在有了物联网、无人机、自动驾驶汽车、防篡改保护。
There's so many different things now that are requiring low level firmware or or low-level software engineers, that it definitely would be a great field. If you're interested in that, you should definitely look at the future. Don't look at right now or look at five years ago where cloud was so big. Look at sort of what you want to do, and if you're passionate about that, you should definitely go for it. There'll be tons of opportunity. Exactly.
现在有太多不同的东西需要底层的固件或底层的软件工程师，这绝对是一个伟大的领域。如果你对此感兴趣，你绝对应该放眼未来。不要看现在或者看看五年前云计算有多火的时候。看看你想做什么，如果你对此充满热情，你绝对应该去追求它。会有源源不断的机会。没错。
I mean, if you look at where things are going with IOT the Internet of Things I mean pretty much everything is gonna have a some kind of microcontroller in it and it's both wonderful between a very scary thing that your light bulbs could potentially be you know compromised by someone mm-hmm or worse stop lights your car and this is scary scary stuff so we need smart people to help solve these problems. Yeah, you know, in the security developer space, there's a very big demand and not a whole lot of supply. So if someone is looking to diversify
我的意思是，如果你看看物联网的发展趋势，物联网，我的意思是几乎所有东西都将内置某种微控制器，这既奇妙又是一件非常可怕的事情，你的灯泡可能会被某人破坏，嗯，或者更糟的是，红绿灯，你的汽车，这些都是可怕的可怕的事情，所以我们需要聪明的人来帮助解决这些问题。是的，你知道，在安全开发人员领域，有非常大的需求，但供给却不多。所以如果有人想多元化发展
or just to create a niche for themselves, and they like coding, security space is really a great place to be. It's like doing puzzles. If you like to think, if you like to think through hard problems, it's very rewarding and you'll find a lot of opportunity. And so, you know, get good on tools like, you know, Intel Tamper Protection Toolkit and get good with disassemblers. And you'll find yourself, as you spend time doing that, you're the go-to guy for anything security.
或者只是为自己创造一个利基市场，并且他们喜欢编程，安全领域真的是一个好去处。这就像做拼图游戏。如果你喜欢思考，如果你喜欢攻克难题，这是非常有回报的，你会发现很多机会。所以，你知道，熟练掌握诸如英特尔防篡改工具包之类的工具，并且精通反汇编程序。随着你花时间去做这些，你会发现自己成为任何安全问题的首选专家。
And just by getting familiar with some of those tools and some of the thinking patterns that Mark mentioned, you'll find your career growing in a wonderful way. Yeah, start by trying to break stuff and then worry about securing it later. That's my recommendation there. mentioned, you'll find your career growing in a wonderful way. Yeah. Start by trying to break stuff and then worry about securing it later. That's my recommendation there. But keep yourself, it'll keep you up at night. I don't know.
只要熟悉其中一些工具和马克提到的思维模式，你就会发现自己的职业生涯在向着美好的方向发展。是的，从尝试破坏东西开始，然后再担心如何保护它。这就是我的建议。提到，你就会发现自己的职业生涯在向着美好的方向发展。是的。从尝试破坏东西开始，然后再担心如何保护它。这就是我的建议。但让你自己，它会让你夜不能寐。我不知道。
I read like, I remember back in school, I would read like Kevin Mitnick's book about social engineering or whatever and be like, oh, oh man, this is not good. Yeah. Everything in the world is just vulnerable. Yeah. Yeah. Or go play eve online wait what go play eve online what is what's the connection that'll keep you up oh i see yeah that will that will you'll stay up all night playing even managing the security and things like and trust and things like that okay oh i see. Oh, I see the social network there. Okay, that makes sense.
我读过，我记得在学校时，我会读凯文·米特尼克的关于社会工程学的书之类的，然后会觉得，哦，哦天哪，这可不太好。是的。世界上的所有东西都是脆弱的。是的。是的。或者去玩EVE Online。等等，什么？去玩EVE Online。有什么联系？那会让你彻夜难眠。哦，我明白了。是的，那会，你会整晚玩EVE，管理安全之类的事情，还有信任之类的事情。好吧，哦，我明白了。哦，我看到了那里的社交网络。好吧，这说得通。
I've heard crazy stories of 20,000 hours of work getting just destroyed in some battle. It's unbelievable. Actually, even worse than that, 20,000 hours of work gets destroyed by someone who you trusted who ended up turning on you and stealing your stuff. And that's supposed to be fun it sounds like real life i have that part of it again for people who think that way it can be interesting how do you protect it sounds awesome how do you protect you know i know somebody who doesn't
我听说过疯狂的故事，2万小时的工作在一场战斗中就被毁了。这简直难以置信。事实上，比那更糟糕的是，2万小时的工作毁于一个你信任却最终背叛你并偷走你东西的人。这本该很有趣，听起来就像现实生活。我又有了那一部分。对于有这种思维方式的人来说，这可能很有趣。你如何保护它？听起来棒极了。你如何保护，我知道有人不
i know somebody who doesn't even play that much, but through his, I guess, social graces, is able to just have incredible wealth on EVE Online just because he's on the top of kind of, I guess, I don't want to say a pyramid scheme, but he's built like a multi-level marketing. Exactly. It's a great model of the real world. Right.
我知道甚至不怎么玩的人，但通过他的，我猜，社交风度，仅仅因为他处于某种，我不想说传销骗局的顶端，但他建立了一个多层次营销网络，就能在EVE Online中拥有惊人的财富。没错。这是现实世界的绝佳模型。对的。
Cool. Thank you guys so much for coming on the show I'll post a link to your email addresses if people want to reach out to you you know if they want to come and work with you guys
太酷了。非常感谢你们来参加节目。我会发布一个指向你们电子邮件地址的链接，如果人们想联系你们，你知道，如果他们想和你们一起工作，
or if they just have questions about tamper protection or if their trial expired and they want to beg you guys for another 30 days or something so I expired and they want to beg you guys for another 30 days or something. I have a way to contact you guys. This has been absolutely fascinating. Thanks again for coming on the show. It's totally awesome.
或者如果他们对防篡改有疑问，或者如果他们的试用期过期了并想向你们乞求再来30天左右的话，如果过期了并想向你们乞求再来30天左右的话。我有一种联系你们的方式。这绝对太迷人了。再次感谢你们来参加节目。真是太棒了。
Thanks, guys. Pleasure. our pilot. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢你们，伙计们。很荣幸。我们的导语。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子来留下评论。